hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter ten of the categories
aristotle distinguished between four
main kinds of opposition ways in which
terms or things can be opposed to each
other and the fourth type that he talks
about is really quite interesting it's
unlike the other types in that it is you
might say purely a matter of language or
thought and it is affirmation and denial
one of the things that makes this
particularly interesting is that we can
use language or are thinking which
Aristotle thinks is very much like
language on the inner heads to refer to
the other kinds of opposition's for that
for example those of contraries are
those of positives and privations or
those of correlatives now the terms that
aristotle uses here are rather technical
terms
there is cotta fascist and Apple fascist
cotta is you know literally means
downward so think of sort of saying down
saying this is the way things are you
laying things out in speech a poll means
a way the fascist is coming from
speaking right so saying no no it's not
that it's something else instead
and by Aristotle's time and especially
in Aristotle's work these come to mean
what we call affirmation saying
something is the case in denial it's
opposite saying that something is not
the case
and Aristotle clarifies that what we
mean when we talk about Cotta fascist is
a logos a statement a verbal or we could
say mental entity logos cotta thought
seacoast so a statement that is
affirming an affirmative statement
affirmation is affirmative statement
denial is
negation Allah or negating statement we
can say denying statement so this is a
very important point to keep in mind and
again keep it keep in mind as well that
Aristotle doesn't think this is just in
language but also can be in thought
which work which works like language
itself we can engage in kata faxes or
apophysis as activity now he also points
out that what is affirmed or denied what
the language is about right what is
affirmed or denied is not itself
affirmation or denial it's not as he
says a logos there could of course be
counter examples to this that he doesn't
consider for example when we're using
language meta linguistically and we are
talking about the language itself but
even then there's a there's a difference
going on it's true that it is they logos
but it's not being treated as a logos in
that case it is being treated perhaps as
a subject of which things are being
predicated or you know in this case
affirmed or denied or it's being treated
as we might say an object something that
language can be referring to this is an
interesting facet of language we can set
that aside and we can think instead
about the sort of examples that that
Aristotle uses the person sits the
person does not sit right the person
actually sitting is a thing that's
sitting down I'm just minding sitting
down because I don't have a chair right
not sitting of course could be a whole
bunch of things could be standing on
your head could be running around in
circles could be laying down on the
floor could be standing on one knee
could be getting yourself almost ready
to sit but the not sitting so there's
the denial sometimes isn't exactly clear
about about what is the case but it's
clear about what is not the case and so
Aristotle says that the person sitting
or
our the person not sitting it's not the
same thing as the statement about that
and why does he make this point because
there are cases where people lose sight
of this and they confuse the thing
itself that's being referred to or the
sets of things arranged in certain ways
with what is being said about them the
opposition that's happening here is
primarily between logos counterfeit
echoes you know speaking that is
asserting something and logosophical
speaking that is denying something those
are the things that are actually being
opposed here now he says that what is
affirmed or denied are in fact opposed
or opposites in the same way as the
statements themselves because the
statements themselves are in a certain
way mirroring the realities that are
that are under discussion or perhaps
being imagined right because as we're
going to see Aristotle is going to talk
about how we also do this with non
existent things in just a moment but
it's very important to keep this in mind
things can be opposed to each other
the person sits the person does not sit
that's referring to you know people in
the world or that you know the chalk is
white the chalk is not white right the
chalk is white is a cat a fascist the
chalk is not white is an oppo fascist
the chalk being white is not itself a
kind of fascist it is not an affirmation
it's just the quality in the chalk that
we're referring to in language we are
affirming whiteness of the truck and we
could deny whiteness of the truck as
well so those things are opposites in
the same sense you know if you somehow
the truck becomes different colored
maybe becomes transparent it's no longer
white right that's an opposite but
that's an opposite in a in the thing and
not in the affirmation and denial
Aristotle seems to say
that the verbal things can follow on the
reality of the the things and their
possibilities so he goes on and he says
something else that's really quite
interesting one of the two opposite
statements must be true and the other
false so if you think about it he is
sitting he is not sitting right if
somebody exists either they're sitting
at any given point in time or they're
not sitting and you can say well wait a
second what about people who you know
sit and then they get up okay now you're
bringing time into it and we can just
say at any given point in time look
either you're sitting or you're not
sitting either either you're living or
you're dead you know either the chalk is
white or it's not white notice what he
doesn't say either the chalk is white or
it's black no because there's other
possibilities for color right now
what about non-existent objects this is
where it gets really interesting
he says he's considering all these
different ways in which we can talk
about things either being true or not
true to return to affirmation and
negation of these we may say in all
cases that one must be false and the
other true whether the subject exists or
not how is that the case as you say says
well think about existing first if
Socrates really exists he is ill or not
ill must be true he is ill or not ill
must be false one of the others is true
the same if he does not exist why it
would seem that if he doesn't exist all
bets are off right we can imagine
anything we like about non-existent
things
Aristotle treats this in a kind of
hypothetical way he says provided he
does not exist and it's false to
pronounce he is ill he is he is not ill
however becomes true even if he doesn't
exist if we can say that one of them is
false by assumption then the other one
becomes true so he says thus that one
- must be true and the other be false in
all cases will hold these opposites only
which are in the same sense opposed as
affirmative and negative statements so
there's something really unique to this
type of opposition that imposes even on
non existent imaginary things that one
statement must be true and the other
statement must be false now it doesn't
mean that we automatically know which
one of them is true and which one of
them is false we might you know there
might be no way to decide that or you
might just decide it by Fiat this is
what often what happens when people tell
stories isn't it you know think about an
imaginary universe you know those of
science-fiction for example where people
play fast and loose with faster than
light travel you know if you think
faster than light travel is possible
because these aliens have it and they
share it with human beings then that
becomes true within that that set of
assumptions that fictional world and
faster than light travel is not possible
becomes a false statement and notice
that you can have people in those
fictional universes arguing about
whether it's true or false you know and
they may find it by experimentation but
only if it met that fictional universe
not out in the world that that were
inhabiting and presumably we share in
some sort of long continuity with
Aristotle so another very important type
of opposition cata fascist and appa
fascist affirmation and denial has to do
primarily with language or our thought
about things rather than the things
themselves although it refers to those
things